Back in 2015,
I hated the idea of doing
any sort of stuff
that involved G-forces.
It absolutely terrified me.
You can see that the very
first time that I did
a loop in a glider.
Oh boy!
Oh boy, oh boy,
oh boy, oh boy!
Don't freak out, don't
freak out, don't freak out.
I was freaked out the whole time,
but since then I've done so much stuff
in so many wonderful things
that I've learned to love it.
And I want to do it again.
So I figured, I'd invite a friend.
Hello.
That was natural, wasn't it?
I was waiting poised just off camera
to walk perfectly-on-cue in.
Yup.
No, it's... this is the first video that
we're filming for this channel.
We have no idea...
Like we've got a camera op,
we've got a producer.
I have no idea what's going to happen now.
Well, neither do I.
I got a text from you a while back,
and you said, "How do you
feel about aerobatics?"
And I had no idea what you meant.
I didn't know you were
inviting me to do a video.
I just thought you're asking my opinion.
So I said, "Yeah, sounds fun."
And then you said, "Okay,
great, we'll do a video."
And I also decided not to
Google what aerobatics is,
because I imagine whatever
you have planned for today,
it's bound to have safety harnesses
coming out of my ear holes.
How dangerous could it be?
First things first,
I'm not flying you.
Oh good.
This is the British Aerobatic Academy.
So these are the pilots who
teach pilots to do aerobatics.
By which you mean we are in arguably
the safest possible place we could be
for being flown in a tiny plane.
I'm not qualified to fly this.
I'm frankly not qualified to go near it
without someone else around.
So, also here, standing awkwardly
out of the camera shot...
Introduce yourself, please.
I'm Joe. Welcome to the
British Aerobatics Academy.
The two planes we're going to
be flying today, both Extras.
This is the Extra 300.
And out there we've got an Extra 200.
The only difference is this
one is slightly bigger.
And the thing in the
front that pulls you along
has got a hundred more horsepower.
Right, okay.
The guy in charge of
our safety called it
"the thing in the front
that pulls you along"!
They both are very capable and can do
every aerobatic manoeuvre that
you would ever dream about
and probably not dream about.
I'm nervously looking
around for one of those signs
that says "X number of
days without an accident".
(all laugh)
Do you want me to show you guys around?
Yeah.
Yes, please! Let's see the plane.
My wife has insisted that I text her
the minute we land, because
she's really worried.
I feel like she's more worried
than you at this point?
Right, it's either that I have
perfect confidence in
Joe and in the system
or I'm just blocking it out of my mind.
So this is what you're
going to be sitting in.
As you can see, there's not much room.
You guys will be in the front, and
the instructor will be in the back.
The main thing for you guys in the front,
is probably that little paper thing there.
Okay.
Hang on.
Is it a sick bag?
It's a sick bag.
Ah, okay.
Good, yes.
It's got a five point harness.
So any negative or positive G,
you shouldn't move out of your seat.
"Shouldn't" being the keyword.
What happens if we get
bored and want to leave?
(laughs)
Well, we don't have a parachute, so...
if you want to leave...
you're not going to go
home to your wife.
Ooh!
That was more bleak than I
thought it was going to be.
Am I imagining that this thing is
literally held together with duct tape?
Yes.
"Yes, I'm imagining it"?
That is not a critical
part of the aeroplane.
That is more just for
people in competitions
and to get the plane
going dead straight up.
I like this casual mention,
"Yeah, when you're flying
vertically up, that's..."
He's telling us like
we've got to do the controls.
You have.
Really?
Yes, you'll get a chance to do it.
Ooh. I didn't know that.
I didn't know that until just now.
I thought I was just going
to be sat in the front,
enjoying the view, but you mean
I've got a job to do.
They'll give you a go, yeah.
Oh wow.
Could I endanger us?
No.
Why do you ask these things?!
So that I can hear the
reassuring, "No, of course not.
"We obviously don't let
people do that sort of thing."
It's more the tone of your
voice was like, "oh, can I?!"
Can I kill us both?
Please.
No, obviously you'll have
an instructor in the back,
so they'll be talking you through it all.
I was already like really excited
and now I'm really,
really, really excited.
I'm going to actually kind of
fly a plane and not injure us.
There we go.
That's the important bit.
That's the main bit.
Honestly, coming here,
it's like, it's fine,
I've done this before,
Jay will be nervous.
And now it's kind of the
other way just with the...
I'm excited.
I feel like a boy in an aeroplane hangar.
This still makes me feel
like a big, strong man.
Do you remember those clips of Geoff Capes
pulling a plane all by himself?
That's a reference I
haven't heard in a while.
Shall we leave it here then?
So the plan is that we're
going to depart from here,
we're going to experience a
little bit of formation flying
and how it is flying formation.
Tom, you have some
experience with that before.
Little bit, yeah.
So it's going to be a
bit of a new thing for Jay.
I have no experience with this at all.
See, Tom's got the advantage here
because you've done this before.
Why do you think I invited you?!
So you already know
what your limits are,
and you know what you
like and don't like in a plane.
I have no idea if I'm
going to love it and do,
17 more loops-the-loop
than you do
or if I'm going to feel
sick after two seconds.
See, I think I'm okay with this
because I've done loops and rolls.
I've done a stall turn
and I've done a break,
but I've not gone beyond that.
And I don't know what my limit is.
So it's quite possible that
we're going to get up there
and we're going to get
to that and it's like no,
that's as far as I can go,
and you're going to blast past me.
I have no idea.
So yeah, we'll go on the
trip of pursuing your limits.
So we'll try to find what they are.
We might try multiple rolls
or loops combined with rolls
or some spinning, inverted spinning,
or whatever you prefer.
Should I be filling out some
kind of will before I go up?
I hope you guys will enjoy it.
Any questions?
Yeah, is it at all possible
for me to endanger us?
Pardon?
Can you phrase that
differently, Jay?!
That sounds like
you're asking permission!
Can I (bleep) up?
Step on the cushions.
So I'm standing on the cushions.
Yep.
Stand on the cushions.
On the cushions just here, yep.
I said "stand on the cushions"
and I didn't stand on the cushions.
Never felt safer in my life.
Right, excellent.
I do wonder how Jay's feeling,
because he's had this kind of "I'm fine,
"I'm all calm, nothing
can go wrong" demeanour.
And I wonder how he's feeling right now.
Hey, Tom.
We can communicate from
plane to plane like this.
How are you feeling?
I'm still feeling kind of numb.
I'm sort of waiting for
the nerves to set in.
I reckon it'll happen
as soon as we take off.
Tom, ready to take off?
Brilliant.
♪ Da da da da da da ♪
♪ Da da da da dun dun ♪
♪ Da dum ba da dum dum ♪
(Jay and pilot laugh)
(laughs)
Oh, wow.
(yelling)
(laughs)
Ooh!
And now's the complete shape.
That's Jay, over there.
Yes!
(indistinct radio chatter)
There's our heading.
And ease on the rails.
♪ (energetic rock music)
(laughs)
Wow!
Easy going over the tip.
That was excellent.
(laughs)
Oh, wow!
Okay.
Do you feel okay still?
Yes.
Wow!
There we go,
we'll spin the other way.
Oh!
(indistinct radio chatter)
♪ (music stops)
(laughs)
Wow.
[Formatting: Caption+ by JS*
https://caption.plus]